(rap music)
- Fuck a fucking camera.
Fuck lighting.
Like you've got a phone.
(rap music)
Hey everybody.
Monday, Monday?
Got tricked already.
Tuesday morning.
Headed to Laguardia Airport.
Headed to Kansas City for a
meeting with a potential client
all day and then
flying right back.
Kinda that classic 6, 7 A.M.
to midnight day where
you're going to a city and out.
Anyway hope
you're doing super well.
Been really
focusing on family time as
you guys might be noticed.
Trying to spend some time this
summer with them so not sure
I'm gonna pull off a vlog every
day but we'll keep pounding.
Tons of content.
Love the reaction from
the last couple episodes.
So make sure if you
missed late last week,
last three, four or five, really
had a lot of stuff in them but
the Memorial Day weekend threw
off a lot of people so check it.
Hope you're super well.
Let's see what happens today.
Hear DRock's up to something.
("Legendary" by Rowlan)
What the hell, Reed?
This is my month now.
Why you still in
the stands? (laughs)
- [Marcus] Get stuff
tonight and then make a call.
- My fantasy situation
has not gone well.
And I'm not happy about it.
But I'm happy about
this whole iPhone episode.
- [DRock] What do you think?
- I think it's cool.
I like how you just switched.
- What is the iPhone episode?
- [DRock] Literally
just all shot in an iPhone.
- Oh, I actually really didn't
even notice that until just now.
(DRock laughs)
I like that.
This is a new look for you.
Yeah.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Getting back to the basics.
- [DRock] A little bit lighter.
- Yeah.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- This could be part of
an ad for Apple eventually.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Marcus] I mean
DailyVee as shot on.
- [DRock] As shot on.
- The iPhone.
- [Gary] That being said,
if Android wants to pay up.
(group laughter)
Samsung call me.
- [Dennis] Google,
Google Pixel...
- Yeah,
Michelle Mai or whatever.
- Yeah, hardcore Asian
company with lots of zeros,
you know, we can be sold
on filming different ways.
Do a sponsored DailyVee episode.
Just from a business
case study standpoint.
I'm just like wearing
random shit the whole episode.
I actually believe that
product integration is gonna be
inevitable because ads are just
taking too much time away
and I think that's
where it's all going.
- It's what the
influencer team is.
Essentially, just
in a more basic level.
- Today's Reddit AMA podcast is
getting ridiculous responses.
So show...
If you want big things, you have
to be able to take the risk of
wasting your time because the
upside is if tomorrow Snapchat
comes out with a feature that
crushes it and gets super hot
again, everybody who
jumped off of Snapchat because
Instagram Stories is gonna be sad.
If you haven't
signed up for my podcast,
do that right now.
Here's the link.
And definitely,
definitely, definitely watch,
listen, excuse me,
this Reddit AMA.
And we're gonna
put out the video too.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- [Marcus] There was more beyond
what you can get it on Friday.
- It just came out today.
I did a Reddit AMA.
I filmed it.
- [Marcus] Oh, okay.
- Had my whole team
there it was really cool.
("Legendary" by Rowlan)
Like we just have to get out of,
micro-analyzation while being
empathetic that's what everybody
has to do and not to do.
It's kind of
like my model, right?
Which is like pure offense
but don't put
yourself out of business.
Empathetic that
(censored) you know
bringing up a historical one,
(censored) only
has so many (censored).
I'm empathetic to it.
- [Dennis] Mhmmm.
- But it needs to be talked
about and brought to me versus
slow and friction.
- [Dennis] Mhmmm.
- We have to figure
that out as as company.
Or we get nimble with
all the extra assets we have.
So I think you should
actually spend time on that.
- [Dennis] Yeah.
- And let me rank.
Yeah, that to me is an
interesting conversation.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- Because if I can rank these
type of things one through 37
then we can work backwards.
Because I can give you a read
I kill people that
think they're special.
- [Dennis] Yeah.
("Legendary" by Rowlan)
- Thank you guys.
I'll talk to you later.
Good luck with your flight.
So I'm here at the airport.
Just got like six
internal phone calls done.
Structure, operations,
a little bit of a
strategy where we're going.
Some key hires
that are on their way.
Couple key client decisions.
New product offering.
Sitting delayed here to Newark
after I had a flight
canceled to Laguardia.
Been on six calls,
moving other calls.
Tyler and I are just
texting back and forth.
So just kinda living the
hustle entrepreneur life.
No DRock around to
capture everything.
And just very much focused on
this thought of people's lack of
willingness of
risking their time
as if it's valuable.
I said this a
couple episodes ago,
it's a thing that's super on
my mind which is how are you so
scared to do
things on spec, free work,
try new platforms,
when your time isn't valuable.
You're not crushing it.
You're not making tons of money.
The amount of you that are
beggars as I said and are acting
like choosers blows my mind.
The, I call it ego.
You know, one
thing I'm proud of,
I have ridiculous
amounts of ego.
I'm fucking fired up.
I think I'm the
greatest but in my actions
I deploy massive humility.
I'm always willing
to do shit on spec.
I'm here in Kansas City on spec.
At this point in my career and a
bunch of you just aren't willing
to put in the work
like you're fucking fancy.
Like you're fucking special.
Like you're fucking
LeBron or Barack
or fuckin' Oprah.
Just don't get it.
I do get it actually.
You're just
fucking full of shit.
You're not willing to put in the
work and so you've decided that
you're too fancy to try new apps
because what if
it doesn't get big.
You don't have enough time to
make Instagram
and Snapchat stories?
You don't have time to make
somebody a design or a piece of
content for free?
Like you're something special.
Everybody's fucking special.
You ever see that guy who like
buys Roger Federer's sneakers
("Legendary" by Rowlan)
Just landed in Newark.
Running to make
their connections.
I'm running to make four
more phone calls tonight.
You know, just a
classic day trip to Kansas City.
In and out. That's it.
Just kinda grinded it out.
Went really
well with the client.
Got a lot done on email.
I like the
travel days because two,
three, four, five, six hours of
email time really the only time
I do my email or catch up on
my actual work is when I fly.
So the days are a little bit
more efficient
than people think.
A lot of people ask me why don't
I fly private all the time.
Isn't the time valuable?
The answer is of course other
than the fact that I actually
need the two to four hours of
email to get my shit done so,
really good way to start the
post-Memorial Day weekend.
Feel very accomplished.
Feel like I got a Monday and
Tuesday in on this Tuesday.
And now,
I'm gonna go take this piss
and yeah.
Finally, first time
I'm seeing it in the wild.
What up, Gary?
Hey Gary.
(imitates kissing)
("Callisto" by Alice Fremont)
It's incredible.
We have so many tools.
We're so god damn lucky, Stace.
- [Stacy] I know.
- [Gary] You and I are doing the
drive time radio show right now
that would've cost millions
of dollars to distribute
just 20 years ago.
Fuck a fucking camera.
Fuck lighting.
Like you've got a phone.
Everybody's reading my books and
watching everything and
reading everybody's motivated.
Everybody's
ordering the equipment.
You know who I'm always scared
that all my followers are?
("Callisto" by Alice Fremont)
and wristbands and he's got an
$800 racket and he's got the
headband and the water bottle
and he drinks the $8 fucking
electrolytes coconut water and
he stretches for 15 minutes and
then he goes on the
court and loses six-love?
- [Stacy] Yeah. (chuckles)
- That's what I'm scared of.
What winners do which
is put in the practice.
I want you to take the tennis
ball and hit it against the wall
'cause that's all you've got.
A shitty racket and your wall
and you just keep hitting it
over and over and over again.
because my
salesmanship will be right.